let's check in with ted for a look at
the forecast denise thanks very much and
good evening to you
live look outside right now from a tower
camp very few clouds out there storms
way off in the distance
into arizona and that's where they're
staying at temperature
for the high for the day today 104
degrees our normal 105
see we're just near average 83 again is
what we dropped to
overnight that was our morning start sky
canyon at 100 right now centennial hills
at 101
aliante year 102 105 sunrise mountain
whitney ranch and green valley both at
104 degrees 101 henderson
mountains edge and rhodes ranch you're
currently at 104
elsewhere 98 for prep 102 for boulder
city and 106 for laughlin so where are
the storms at there's our doppler
network pinpointing the storms right now
into arizona specifically mohave county
notice the direction of these storm
tracks moving to the northeast
and that's what these storms are doing
basically firing up and then heading
away from us so that's why we're staying
on the dry side
we knew this was going to happen though
some areas right here near state line
did fire up some storms but fizzled out
before they hit mesquite
possibilities still out there as we head
into sundown but then we get later on in
the evening
notice futurecast does really not show
any chance or any threat of any storms
here so again
going to be another quiet night and
hopefully not a quite monsoon season
because it has been that way so far
i'm tracking hurricane douglas the
reason for that this is the 9th island
we have a lot of islanders out here i
also do the ninth island forecast so
right now it's a
powerful category three hurricane okay
here's its track yes it will be headed
towards hawaii
however it will lose its intensity
possibly making landfall as a category
one hurricane as it hits the big island
goes through oahu
maui lanahi and it heads its way out out
to sea and then decreases even more into
a tropical
storm but we will be watching this as it
will make landfall over the weekend
here's your forecast 78 degrees
overnight mainly clear skies
gusty at times for tonight mainly from
outflow winds
from those storms i've been pointed out
to you 102 degrees for tomorrow
sunny and dry we'll see some south
breezes it could be breezy at times
again for tomorrow too
but it looks like as we head into the
weekend we'll keep around some of those
afternoon winds
but nothing too windy at all 100 for
centennial hills
99 summerlin 101 aliante same goes for
mountains edge and rhodes ranch
105 sunrise mountain we'll be at 99 for
prop 100 for boulder city laflin you'll
have a high tomorrow of 107 degrees
seven-day forecast now shows dry for the
weekend at least here
storms throughout the arizona now next
week we're going to heat things up
but there are some models that are
hinting we could get some moisture
towards the end of the week
right now we're keeping it dry if that
changes our storm tracker 18 will be all
over it we'll throw those storms in
there
that's your most accurate forecast
denise over to you